seht ihr ich bin 72 ich halte den
klimawandel bis zu meinem lebensende ja
noch aus aber wenn ich jetzt 13 oder 14
bin und ich habe so viele jahrzehnte
leben vor mir kann ich unmöglich dass so
weiter laufen lassen und deshalb müssen
die jungen bei den alten an die tür
klopfen und sagen nein nicht für euch
politik machen sondern für uns und damit
für die zukunft und das wird auch
höchste zeit
alle sagen mir greta tun werk sei
merkwürdig wenn sie gewöhnlich wäre
würde sie auch nicht außergewöhnliches
leisten
stark war auch merkwürdig aber hat
außergewöhnliches geleistet das heißt ja
nicht dass man sich gleich als nachbarin
wünscht dieser master ist völlig daneben
und ich sage klipp und klar die greta
thunberg kann was sie hat natürlich weil
sie typisch ist etwas in bewegung
gesetzt wenn man so sagen will nicht
allein sie aber auch sie weltweit und
dass sie etwas geleistet hat kann ich
euch gleich beweisen im unterschied zu
euch ein und mir hat sie 1 geschafft
trump muss sie jetzt 20 minuten zu hören
ich habe selten ein so gequältes gesicht
gesehen dass sich so genossen habe
nochmals zurück zur sozialen
verantwortung ich kann auch nicht sagen
die bauern sollen kein auto haben wenn
einmal am tag ein bus vom dorf zur
kreisstadt fährt dann sage ich nie der
bus muss ihren text mal fahren dann wird
mir gesagt die fünf fahrten rechnen sich
nicht dann sage ich ja und genau dafür
zahl ich steuern nicht für die
ausrüstung sondern für die öffentliche
daseinsvorsorge damit ihn für alle
zugänglich wird
wir haben weltkonzerne berlin hat
darüber gesprochen auch welt banken die
haben eine ungeheure macht und sie üben
den gesamten einfluss auf die politik
aus nicht die merkel entscheidet was der
chef der deutschen bank macht sondern
der chef der deutschen bank entscheidet
was merkel macht so kann einem jahr
beides nicht gefallen es gibt ein
unterschied
indirekt wird ja die merkel gewählt über
demokratische wahlen der bevölkerung der
chef der deutschen bank wird von uns
nicht gewählt weder direkt noch indirekt
noch in anderer form
deshalb ist es eine kernfrage der
demokratie ob die politik über die
wirtschaft oder die wirtschaft über die
politik zu entscheiden hat und das läuft
dergestalt völlig falsch damit wird die
demokratie beschädigt und es gibt immer
mehr menschen die die demokratie gar
nicht wirklich wollen muss man sich
fragen warum das ansehen oder im
gegenteil diese macht der konzerne führt
ja geradezu zu trump was ist denn seine
theorie seine theorie ist er will die
früchte der globalen wirtschafts- in
seinem land haben und die lasten in
anderen ländern das nennt er nationalen
egoismus
so macht er das genauso sieht das
genauso sieht es opern und so genau so
sieht es die afb
genau so sieht es die vom national alle
diese kräfte und sie haben jetzt aufwind
weil die welt so unübersichtlich
geworden ist fangen sie doch mal vor
meinetwegen die sieben monat
bundestagsabgeordneten übrigens 100 zu
viel
fragen sie doch mal was das interesse
von saudi arabien und vom iran am
höhn krieges wenn sie sechs abgeordnete
treffen dienen darauf eine
nachvollziehbare antwort geben dann
erleben sie ein glücksfall wenn die das
aber schon nicht mehr verstehen
wie soll das die allgemeinheit verstehen
und die verunsicherung der allgemeinheit
in all diesen fragen führt dazu dass man
erfolg hat wenn man nationalen egoismus
anbietet wenn man sagt wir bauen in
deutschland darum eine mauer auf was
geht uns überhaupt syrien an
wir haben mit all den problemen nichts
zu tun abgesehen davon dass es
reaktionär ist ist es auch noch
illusionär
das gibt es überhaupt nicht mehr die
menschheit ist so zusammen gerückt dass
jedes problem der menschheit direkt oder
indirekt auch zu uns kommen
wir haben die frage wie bisher es zu
ignorieren oder antworten auf die
sozialen fragen und die ökologische
nachhaltigkeit weltweit zu suchen und zu
finden was sie von der linken verlange
ist dass sie nach diesen antworten sucht
und die gibt und nicht kleinkariert hier
innerhalb unserer strukturen sich äußert
und nachdenkt und warum ist das so
wichtig warum ist das so wichtig
[Applaus]
manchmal ist ja nichts vor wir haben in
europa so gelebt wir wollen europa
gelebt haben weil viele menschen in
afrika gar nicht wussten wie wir leben
nun haben aber die konzerne das handy
gefunden und das internet wissen sie
etwas neues
früher war die nationale frage schon
immer auch eine international aber sie
war vornehmlich eine nationale frage die
soziale frage entschuldung die soziale
frage war vornehmlich eine nationale
frage jetzt haben wir einen weltweiten
lebensstandard vergleich gab es ja
früher nicht und plötzlich ist die
soziale frage ist für eine
menschheitsfrage geworden darauf war
keine einzige regierung vorbereitet
dauert wird jetzt eine reaktionäre
antwort gesucht die übrigens auch das
wesen der gesellschaften deutlich
verändern kann und die linke muss dafür
da sein
diese soziale frage der menschheit zu
beantworten nicht in dem sinne dass es
unserer bevölkerung schlechter gehen
muss sondern in dem sinne dass wir dafür
zu ringen haben dass es anderen
bevölkerung deutlich besser geht
sonst entsteht ein zustand der überhaupt
nicht mehr beherrscht weiß
[Applaus]
aber es ist natürlich auch so dass die
welt immer enger zusammenrückt
nachrichtendienstleister um rohstoffe
produktionsstätten sind von überall
verfügbar von überall steuerbar eine
konzernleitung kann auf jamaika oder in
uganda oder bei uns sitzen das spielt
überhaupt keine rolle mehr
von überall kann sie ihre herrschaft
instrumente einsetzen und nun hätte ist
ja mal dazu gehört dass wir endlich
wenigstens bei den konzerten und in
grossen banken einen riegel vor setzen
und sie gerecht zu steuern heranziehen
wer hat das verhindert in der eu alle
länder waren sich einig dass alle
konzernen und großen banken transparent
nachweisen müssen welche gewinne sie in
portugal in deutschland und sonstwo
machen ein land hat von seinem vetorecht
gebrauch gemacht durch den heldenhaften
sozialdemokraten scholz der hat nein
gesagt deshalb kam das ganze nicht
zustande warum nicht wenn ein an sich
bösartig ist sondern weil er falsche
berater hat die falschen berater haben
ihm gesagt ja unseren mittelstand
exportiert auch viel
dann müssen die in den anderen ländern
steuern bezahlen das könnte uns ruiniert
also sie haben sozusagen panik
organisiert das ist wieder völliger
blödsinn
man kann sagen wie jetzt als ersten
schritt machen wir es für konzerne und
für banken und nicht für den mittelstand
punkt das ist gar nicht schwierig weil
juristisch zwischen beiden kategorien zu
unterscheiden ist mit anderen worten
wenn vernünftige beratung gehabt hätte
werden wir einen deutlichen schritt
weiter
aber die deutschen sozialdemokratie hat
wieder mal verhindert dass wir endlich
transparenz bei den konzernen und banken
innerhalb der europäischen union
herstellen obwohl es so dringend nötig
wäre
dazu muss man auch etwas wissen was
vielleicht nicht allen gefällt
in deutschland wird alles von der mitte
bezahlt die menschen mit kleinen
einkommen können sie ja nicht die mit
großen werden nicht angezogen
die ihr vermögen werden nicht
herangezogen in der wirtschaft ist es
genauso die kleinen selbständigen können
es nicht der mittelstand der muss schon
ehrlich bezahlt und nicht die konzerne
und nicht die banken
ich werde euch was erzählen zu seinem
geburtstag habe ich den präsidenten des
bundesverbandes der mittel
zwischen wirtschaft offen angerufen und
gratuliert weil ich nämlich mitglied
ihres politischen beitrags bin und da
sagte er zu mir ich habe mal eine frage
an sehen also der konzern iks hat gerade
in den gewinn
y gemacht und muss dafür 100 millionen
euro steuern bezahlen wenn sie oder ich
den gewinn gemacht hätten müssten wir
dafür 1,1 milliarden euro steuern
bezahlen können sie mir das erklären ja
sage ich das kann ich ihnen erklären
helfen das liegt daran dass der
bundestag zusammengesetztes wozu sie
ihren beitrag geleistet haben dass das
heißt wir brauchen auch die mittel auch
die mitte ärgert sich darüber dass die
großen banken und konzerne so bevorteilt
werden wie das gegenwärtig der fall ist
und wenn wir die gesellschaft gerecht
finanzieren wollen
geht es nur über die großen und nicht
über die kleinen und wir diskutieren
über jede erhöhung von hartz iv als ob
es die bundesrepublik ruinieren würde
und so gut wie nie über eine gerechte
besteuerung von banken und konzernen und
zwar in ganz europa das geht mir auf die
nerven
die weltweite flucht bewegung ist ja
bisher nur zu einem bruchteil in europa
angekommen ich meine wir haben weltweit
70 millionen flüchtlinge davon 3,1
millionen in europa wir tun immer so als
ob er die 70 millionen hätten es aber
ein schwerer irrtum
das meiste müssen afrikanische länder
lateinamerikanische länder auch
asiatische verkraften und dann leben im
libanon
berechnet auf 1000 einwohnern und
einwohner 164 flüchtlinge in deutschland
leben berechnet auf 1.000 einwohnerinnen
und einwohner 12 flüchtlinge 12 die
update tut so als ob 750 werden aber es
sind nur zwölf und ich bin deshalb
dieses gerede leid ein so reiches land
wie deutschland müsste doch wohl in der
lage seien zwölf flüchtlinge berechnet
auf 1.000 einwohnerinnen und einwohner
ausreichend zu finanzieren heranzuziehen
in den arbeitsmarkt zu integrieren und
alles was dazugehört
und dann
und dann muss man noch wissen dass wir
pro einwohnerin und einwohner das
vierfache bruttoinlandsprodukt im
vergleich zum libanon hat und die
verkraften 164 flüchtlinge übrigens gibt
es natürlich noch was man kann das
problem auf gar keinen fall durch
abschottung und durch deals mit dieser
türkei lösen
das verkennt auch die dimension der
prozesse die dahintersteckt hören sich
die vermögenssituation ansieht ist es so
dass die schere in deutschland europa
und weltweit bei einkommen vermögen
sozialen wirtschaftlichen und
ökologischen bedingungen immer stärker
auseinander klafft also allein 2018
stiegen die vermögen der 1892
milliardäre weltweit um zwölf prozent in
einem jahr
das waren pro tag 2,2 milliarden dollar
in deutschland betrieb bestieg der
antrieb bei diesen leuten sogar 20
prozent also deutlich
überdurchschnittlich während es bei den
3,8 milliarden menschen der ärmeren
hälfte der weltbevölkerung ein rückgang
um elf prozent gab das heißt pro tag
hatten sie 500 millionen dollar weniger
das reichste prozent der deutschen
verfügt über ebenso viel vermögen wie
die 87 ärmeren prozent in den zehn
jahren seit der finanzkrise hat sich die
zahl der milliardäre nahezu verdoppelt
zugleich konnten sich immer weniger
menschen aus extremer armut befreien
2015 lebten weltweit 736 millionen
menschen in extreme armut von weniger
als 1 70 euro pro tag von sozialer
ungleichheit sind vor allem frauen und
mädchen betroffen männer besitzen im
globalen schnitt 50 prozent mehr
vermögen als frauen
zudem sind die gehälter von frauen im
globalen durchschnitt 23 prozent
niedriger als die gehälter von männern
und deshalb würde ich hier mal eins
sagen ich bin auch bestimmte sachen
light eine die böckler stiftung und
andere stiftung die ihn wirklich alle
nicht links sind haben
schon errechnet dass uns 200.000
pflegekräfte fehlen wenn wir dann
wirklich die pflege voranbringen wollen
das ist ein schwerer beruf und viele von
uns haben sich nicht entschieden
pflegerinnen und pfleger zu werden weil
es ein so schwerer beruf ist wenn wir
sie entlasten wollen brauchen wir aber
weitaus mehr pflegerinnen und pfleger
und da sage ich jetzt auch der
gewerkschaft da geht es nicht um eine
lohnsteigerung von fünf oder um 10% hier
müssen wir in eine verdopplung denken so
wichtig ist die pflege in deutschland
geworden also momentan geht die antwort
von trump erdogan orban oder auch bei
den treibenden kräften für den exit in
richtung eines extremen nationalen
egoismus diese art gegenreformation zur
neoliberalen globalisierung läuft längst
uns ist inzwischen in praktisch allen
industriestaaten zu beobachten
wir kennen das trump spricht an amerika
first 1 hatte allerdings begriffen dass
muss ich sagen das ist deshalb
erstaunlich weil ansonsten roulette
kugel im vergleich zu ihm ja eine exakt
berechenbare größe ist weil er abends
nicht mehr weiß was am morgen besitzer
hat aber natürlich können wir
psychologisch schlussfolgern dass ist
ein groß gewordener junge mit
minderwertigkeitskomplexen insbesondere
weil er bei frauen nicht den erfolg hat
den er sich immer gewünscht hat er
braucht psychologische behandlung muss
er darf nicht die machtinstrumente eines
präsidenten der vereinigten staaten in
seine hände bekommen das ist die
eigentliche katastrophe
und ich sage ihnen noch weiß das
schlimme ist dass er begriffen hat im
unterschied zu anderen dass der kalte
krieg vorbei ist damit sich nicht falsch
verstanden werden ich will nicht den
kalten krieg zurück haben aber was heißt
das
stellen sie sich mal vor im kalten krieg
hätten die fünf ständigen mitglieder des
sicherheitsrates usa sowjetunion china
großbritannien und frankreich sich
verständigt das wäre schon die
eigentliche schwierigkeiten gewesen
zusammen mit dem iran ein abkommen zu
machen um die atomare aufrüstung des
iran zu verhindern
wenn das wirklich gelungen wäre während
des kalten krieges niemals hätten die
usa den vertrag gekündigt gar nicht
denkbar
auch nichts ein paris abkommen
gar nicht denkbar auch nicht das
abkommen zwischen der sowjetunion und
den usa zur begrenzung der
mittelstreckenraketen gar nicht denkbar
das hat begriffen dass gilt nicht mehr
er kann den iran zum hauptfeind erklären
andere nato staaten machen es eben nicht
die türkei als nato-mitglied marschiert
völkerrechtswidrig in den syrien ein
anderer staaten interessiert ihn
überhaupt nicht mehr
deshalb hat man gesagt die nato schon
tot und wir hätten sie schon 1990
überwinden können wenn es denn einen
entsprechenden politischen willen
gegeben hätte
der leider eben fehlte aber wir können
all diese interne tendenzen in polen
ungarn dänemark den niederlanden
österreich auch in italien wo es jetzt
wieder ein bisschen überwunden ist aber
es kann auch wieder dahin zurückgehen
und wir müssen uns darüber klar machen
wir dürfen der afg niemals einen
millimeter entgegenkommen sondern wir
müssen die leute vom gegenteil
überzeugen das mag ja anstrengend sein
aber vor dieser anstrengung dürfen wir
uns nicht drücken ganz klar die afg ist
ein sammelbecken für neonazis holocaust
leugner und rassisten
wir haben auch sonst schwierigkeiten mit
dem recht und gesetz fast jeder zehnte
abgeordnete der afc im bund und ländern
sieht sich einem ermittlungsverfahren
ausgesetzt werden was jeder zehnte
abgeordnete muss man sich mal überlegen
die fdp vorsitzenden parteien und
fraktionen lassen sich von dubiosen
spendern finanzieren und nennen der
bundestagsverwaltung falsche namen womit
sie jetzt glücklicherweise auf die füße
fallen werden die fdp hält eben wie auch
drum den klimawandel für eine erfindung
vor allem aber hat sie überhaupt keine
konzepte wie wir unser land europa und
die welt menschlicher sozialer und
ökologisch nachhaltiger gestalten können
die afg ist schlicht und einfach eine
feige und armselige partei warum feige
sie kämpfen gegen die schwächsten in der
gesellschaft welche lobby handeln die
flüchtlinge so gut wie keine
das muss sich uns linken lassen wir
kämpfen immerhin gegen die stärksten in
der gesellschaft und dabei muss es auch
bleiben
im kern geht es um die frage vor der
hier auch in deutschland stehen wird die
demokratie weiter marktkonform
zugerichtet damit ihren ihrem wesen
zerstört oder können wir auf
demokratischem wege märkten kapital
regeln aufzwingen und damit die
interessen der mehrheit der bevölkerung
durchsetzt die rechte knüpft national
und europäisch an dieser neoliberalen
zerstörung der demokratie an und will
demokratische strukturen und grundrechte
direkt angreifen
wir werden der verunsicherung und ihrer
folgen nicht herr werden wenn die
menschen sich wieder eine perspektive
für ein einigermaßen planbares leben und
sozialer in öffentlicher sicherheit
bekommt und der alte grundsatz wieder
geltung erlangt dass eltern wissen ihren
kindern wird es einmal besser gehen
das wissen sie heute nicht mehr sie sind
sogar tief verunsichert das alles hat
konsequenzen
es ist höchste zeit den nationalen
egoismus zu überwinden
er hat auch für die zukunft keine chance
gerade weil von rechtsaußen mit
hassparolen pöbeleien auf der straße und
im internet gewalttaten die solidarität
in der gesellschaft grundlegend infrage
gestellt wird muss es ein gegengewicht
geben ein gesellschaftliches lager der
solidarität das niemanden ausgrenzt dies
muss verbunden werden mit einem kampf
gegen die kapital macht der konzerne für
eine überwindung der sozialen spaltung
eine rückgewinnung des öffentlichen und
ökologische nachhaltigkeit in sozialer
verantwortung vernünftige gesellschaften
sind zu schaffen nur so könnten übrigens
die 20er jahre wirklich goldene werden
nun muss ich aber noch über zwei
aufklären dazu muss ich folgendes
erklären ihr könnt alle sehr intelligent
und klug sein aber weise ist man erst
mit 70 das kann man natürlich nur
einschätzen wenn man selber 70 geworden
ist sonst unterliegt meine illusionen
deshalb werde ich euch jetzt eine
weisheit verkünden
jede positive erscheinung hat auch eine
negative seite und jede negative
erscheinung hat auch eine positive seite
das positive am brett ist dass allen
anderen eu-ländern zur zeit der austritt
vergangen es weil dieses affentheater
will sich ja keiner antun und das gute
an einer fehlentwicklung der
gesellschaft ist dass sich immer mehr
menschen zusammenfinden um doch eine
gegensteuerung zu ermöglichen
auch das beruhigt mich aber warum es
eigentlich das ansehen der etablierten
parteien so schlecht geworden
das hat zwei gründe einmal die falsche
sprache ich werde euch eine geschichte
erzählen der kanzler hieß noch schröder
ist also ewig her und es ging in einer
debatte um die veräußerungserlös steuern
und die veräußerung der
veräußerungsgewinn nervös steuer und die
veräußerungsgewinn erlös steuer mussten
unter kohl kapitalgesellschaften und
voller höhe bezahlen inhaber unternehmen
nur zur hälfte und das wurde geändert
die kapitalgesellschaften boden befreit
die inhaber unternehmen mussten das
doppelte bezahlen so gegen die ganze
debatte dass kaum ein mensch verstehen
kann was ein veräußerungserlös
gewinnsteuern interessierte die halle
nicht dabei ich daran wie ich meinen
endlich andere dachten schade
und dann war ich dran und sagte also
noch mal ganz langsam damit einer wie
ich das auch versteht das ist
selbstironisch ist ganz wichtig sie darf
niemals sagen
damit es die verkäuferin versteht dann
beleidige ich sie also nehme ich mich
selbst und sage dann wird es einer wie
ich auch versteht es wirkt bescheiden
ist in wirklichkeit natürlich die
höchste form der augen weil ich ja weil
ich ja heimlich hoffe dass sie alle
denken ja wir uns schon verstanden haben
aber trotzdem so mein einleitungssatz
und dann sage ich also unter kohl war es
so wenn die deutsche bank den kaufpreis
bekam musste sogar auf eine volle steuer
bezahlen und wenn der bäckermeister
kaufpreis bekam musste er darauf eine
halbe steuer bezahlen
und jetzt erleben wir eine sozial
ökologische reform und die besteht darin
dass die deutsche bank nicht mehr zu
bezahlen braucht und der bäckermeister
der doppelte bezahlen muss das thema
setzen
meine rede war zu ende und ich schwöre
es 15 abgeordnete der spd rannten nach
vorne zum damaligen
fraktionsvorsitzenden strom
und fragten ob es stimmt ob es das ist
was sie in einer halben stunde
entscheiden
ich sagte zu ihrer verteidigung als
anwalt bei veräußerungserlös gewinn
steuer gehen deren ohren auch zu aber
wenn ich mitglied einer
regierungsfraktion bin und ich
beschließe eine halbe stunde später
neues geltendes recht der bundesrepublik
deutschland muss ich doch wenigstens
wissen was ich damit schließe nur durch
mich wussten sie es struck war
entsprechend sauer auf mich
kohl weniger obwohl ich nicht glaube
dass er wusste dass das zurzeit hat seit
zug gerät etwa das spielt ja auch da
keine rolle der traf mich dann auf den
firmenwert co-trainer der energie weh
aber ich sehe mir einziehen verstand
immer anhänger des bag am etwas noch nie
der deutschen bank was was zwar
politisch falsches aber kulturell stimmt
kulturell stimmt ist das ist der eine
grund der zweite grund ist dass
argumente nicht nach prinzipien verwandt
werden sondern wie man sie braucht das
muss die bevölkerung gar nicht so im
detail mit kriegen sie bekommt es vom
prinzip her mit ich werde euch ein
beispiel setzen als der krieg gegen den
usa asien geführt wurde
ich war strikt dagegen meine ganze
partei war strikt dagegen
da habe ich natürlich auch vier augen
gespräche geführt da haben sie gar nicht
bestritten dass das völkerrechtswidrig
ist aber sie haben zu mir gesagt die
serben verletzen die menschenrechte der
kosovo albaner im kosovo albaner
vielleicht beginnt sogar ein völkermord
und rg sie da ist es uns egal selbst als
völkerrechtswidrig ist wir müssen die
bundeswehr hin schicken um das ganze zu
stoppen
wut ist ja nicht meine meinung aber wenn
das deine meinung ist kannst du heute
nicht die bevölkerung überzeugen davon
waffen an saudi arabien zu liefern und
zwar nicht nur bei saudi arabien im
innern die menschenrechte verletzt
sondern saudi arabien führt gegen den
iran um den nehmen einen
stellvertreterkrieg dann nutzen sie ihre
boote regeln ganze gegen dann ab und
lassen weder medikamente noch
lebensmittel in diese gegenden durch und
deshalb verhungert dort die bevölkerung
und stirbt an krankheiten das ist ein
beginn der völker
so und wenn du einmal in der politik saß
das ist so schlimm dass sich sogar
völkerrechtswidrig die bundeswehr hin
schicke und denn im anderen fall saß das
ist mir so was von schmutz ich verkaufe
trotzdem meisten waffen und kriege mein
geld dafür
machst du dich im restlos unglaubwürdig
und deshalb sei und deshalb sage ich
immer genau das muss die politik die
etablierte politik überwinden das heißt
sie muss einfach ehrlicher werden im
verhältnis zur bevölkerung und in ihrer
argumentation was sie nicht ist
nun wird immer gesagt dass auch wir
wähler an die fdp verloren haben dazu
will ich auch mal eine prinzipielle
sache sagen das stimmt aber die sind wir
auch für immer los und ich sag auch
welche das sind diejenigen die uns wegen
unserer linken überzeugungen gewählt
haben haben uns nie verlassen
aber wir hatten welche die haben uns nur
gewählt als protest gegen die anderen
parteien und sie wussten von csu bis zu
grün ärgern sich alle am meisten über
die wahl der linken
das stimmt er damals auch und die wählen
heute afd weil man sich über unsere wahl
nicht mehr so ärgert wie damals die
wache update dafür haben die eine sinken
leidet meine partei darunter und sagt
immer wir sind die protestpartei ja 60
das können wir auch jeden tag erklären
das problem ist nur wir sind in der
regierung in brandenburg gewesen und in
mecklenburg vorpommern jetzt sind wir in
der landesregierung in berlin
wer stellt den ministerpräsidenten von
thüringen da kann es ja man kann sagen
du bist die prozentpunkte plus keiner
mehr
das heißt was müssen wir eigentlich
können wir müssen verantwortlich auch so
frisch mitgestalten können und trotzdem
grundsatzfragen stellen womit wir viele
dinge die so einfach hingenommen werden
in frage stellen das ist unsere aufgabe
diese dopplung müssen wir hinkriegen und
zwar nicht gegeneinander
weil der eine ist immer besser weiß als
der andere sondern miteinander
und wenn wir das in unserer politik
deutlich machen dann können wir auch
weitere erfolge erzielen 1 haben wir
immerhin erreicht vor 1989 war eine
partei links von der spd im bundestag
undenkbar jetzt ist sie zur
selbstverständlichkeit geworden
ein
weit haben wir die bundesrepublik
deutschland verändert nun versucht die
afd
die gegenteilige entwicklung und hier
müssen wir mit anderen zusammen stehen
und diese entwicklung aufhalten
wir dürfen die geschichte nicht um 90
jahre zurückdrehen ich bin es leid nicht
die vergangenheit ist unsere zukunft
sondern eine menschliche gesellschaft
das muss unsere zukunft sein
dafür müssen wir euch streit und alles
verhalten ich wünsche euch tolle erfolg
bei der kommunalwahl und sage euch ich
habe wie immer zu lange gesprochen aber
ich habe es gerne getan
[Applaus]